[Musique]
comment avez vous choisi votre
profession votre métier comment avez
vous fait pour être là où vous êtes
aujourd'hui vraiment comment vous avez
choisi entre risques sécurité vous a été
poussé par votre parent vous avez peur
du chômage
quel choix vous avez fait parce que des
choix on en fait tous on commence quand
on est tout petit et qu'on vous demande
tu préfère manger une cuillère
d'asticots par jour une mygale par mois
ça n'impacte pas énormément mais ce sont
vos premiers choix on arrive ensuite en
cinquième espagnol allemand
ensuite la troisième un bac pro bac
général d'autres voient peut-être on
arrive à 18 ans à devoir choisir sa voie
professionnelle
alors qu'on n'a même pas l'âge de boire
une bière dans un resto américain mais
comment avez vous su que vous aviez fait
le bon choix
est-ce que vous avez déjà su que vous
aviez fait le bon choix
vraiment c'est pas des questions
rhétoriques je me demande vraiment moi
j'ai 21 ans jean master de finance et
j'ai un petit peu peur de m'être trompé
vous souvenez de vos rêves d'enfants
qu'est-ce que vous rêviez de fer
maîtresse d'école caissière astronautes
moi quand j'étais petit je rêvais d'être
jamie vous souhaitez jamy de c'est pas
sorcier sur france 3 j'adorais ça avec
de la science à les transmettre je
trouvais ça génial et aujourd'hui je
suis en master de finance alors je me
demande un petit peu qu est ce qui n'est
arrivé
alors aujourd'hui je me dis est ce que
tu vas rester en finance et finalement
je me dis peut-être pas toute ma vie
est-ce que c'est grave de cette trompe
et après tout alors je me suis tourné
vers mes parents mes collègues de
travail mais proche des professeurs et
je leur ai demandé bah je suis quoi
sérieusement je fais quoi j'arrête mes
études je fais quoi et finalement il ya
eu autant de réponses de que deux
personnes que j'ai pu interroger
je suis la version soit trader pendant
dix ans et va bronzer au soleil après
fait finances finalement ça peut-être
peut-être que tu vas aimer je monte une
boîte change de diplômes j'ai eu toutes
sortes de versions
et finalement le plus intéressant n'a
pas été ce que j'ai répondu puisque je
n'en sais fichtrement rien mais bien ce
que les personnes m'ont répondu et à
quel point la génération influencer sur
leur réponse je dis bien la génération
et non pas l'âge parce qu'une personne
de 20 ans une personne de 50 ans bien
évidemment n'ont pas les mêmes
aspirations professionnelles et de la
génération
je suis né en 1995 ce qui fait de moi un
membre de la génération z est ce que
vous connaissez la génération z
c'est une génération qui est née après
1994 enfants légitimes d'une société en
plein bouleversement et qui aujourd'hui
se retrouvent au milieu de toutes ces
technologies et qui est la dernière mise
à jour de l'espèce humaine
avec la greffe d'un nouvel organe que
vous connaissez le smartphone vous en
avez tous j'imagine le smartphone ce tgv
cérébrale qui va de lloyd au pouce à
tout changer parce qu'aujourd'hui si je
veux connaître le régime alimentaire des
pandas de chine à 3 heures du matin et
bas messieurs dames je peux le savoir
vous êtes que pour vous ça ne change
rien mais en fait ça a tout changé
j'étais en primaire avec google msn au
collège facebook au lycée aujourd'hui
instagram qui nous reste et je vous en
passe mais alors est-ce que cette
génération est bien accueillie eh bien
figurez-vous hier soir je lisais un
article dans le train un article du
point
il y avait un portrait mais tant de
douceur sur ma génération narcissique
accros aux réseaux sociaux
shootée à la 4g ivre de wifi qu'est ce
que j'avais d'autres un but de même bien
évidemment bref des gens magnifiques et
sympathique mais alors cette génération
était vraiment horrible
pourtant nous allons devoir collaborer
vous et moi on va devoir travailler
ensemble parce qu'aujourd'hui sur le
marché du travail
il ya trois lions générationnel
les baby boomers
ils sont nés entre 1950 et 1965 ils ont
connu l'essor de l'emploi ils sont plus
attirés par la hiérarchie la structure
ensuite on a les x entre 1965 et 1980
eux c'est le revers de la médaille
l'emploi n'étaient pas forcément très
bien ils ont dû persévérer travailler et
puis les y
les grecs seller 1981 1995 ils ont vu
leur part
trim et au travail ils ont vu leurs
parents se faire virer malheureusement
après des années de bons et loyaux
services
là le grès qui dit stop moi je veux pas
que ça moi je serai entrepreneurs de ma
peau de ma propre vie
alors vous imaginez bien les petits des
patrons de génération x et les jeunes
générations y ça va pas le faire et là
miracle sur leurs chevaux blancs
arrivent les aides alors déjà qu'on a du
mal à gérer les ambitions dit y voilà qu
on doit se taper les aides enfants de
mères technologie biberonné à google
facebook
instagram qui vont chasser des pokémon
dans les champs super on adore mais en
fait les aides
eux ils sont plutôt simples qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent au travail les aides ils
répondent à 50% selon les études être
entrepreneur si génial mais vous et moi
on sait très bien que 50% de ma
génération ne va pas entreprendre ne va
pas monter sa boîte
non ça veut dire quoi pour un jeune
entreprendre pas pour un jeune c'est
construire sa place c'est quand même
très floues comme concept
c'est dire moi j'ai des connaissances et
des compétences je veux les mettre au
service d'une entreprise et en échange
l'entreprise va me donner son savoir un
partage mutuel de connaissances et c'est
là où le z se dit comme les grecs je
veux être entrepreneur de ma vie mais
plus encore je vais être entrepreneur de
mon savoir
j'apprendrai de l'entreprise de mon
diplôme mais également de moi car
aujourd'hui avec les nouvelles
technologies vous avez des cours en
ligne toutes sortes de choses où vous
pouvez être diplômé d'harvard de
polytechnique en passant quelques heures
par semaine sur internet et ça ça change
tout alors aujourd'hui entreprendre ne
sera le type a juste aspirer à connaître
les sujets pour mieux les maîtriser et
innover sommes nous alors si différent
nous plaît x y et z les baby boomers et
bientôt les alfa là vous me regardez
tous comme si j'étais un petit peu
utopiste c'est quand même idéalistes
comme version est ce que ma génération
est une génération d'idéalistes de
rêveurs décaler la réalité je suis né en
je fais donc je vous ai dit partie la
génération z ma petite serre a été la
crise économique
je n'ai pas connu la baguette à 3 francs
j'ai connu plus de remaniement
ministériel que président de la
république je crois plus au monstre du
loch ness qu'à la retraite à 60 ans et à
l'école on m'a appris que
malheureusement notre planète serait à
perte avec comme dernière échéance 2050
je ne pense pas que la génération z
c'est une génération d'ingrats de
pourris gâtés avec un smartphone dans la
bouche
je ne pense pas que nous soyons c'est
différent nous sommes différents puisque
inégaux sur notre contexte de vie comme
mon grand père a eu 13 ans on
connaissait la fin la seconde guerre
mondiale comme mon père a eu 13 ans il
connaissait les premières crises
pétrolières qui ont donné la fin en fait
aux trente glorieuses comme moi j'ai eu
13 ans c'était début de la crise de la
crise économique sommes nous alors si
différents je ne suis pas un membre d'un
génération z
non je suis un membre de la société est
une société que vous nous avez
transmises avec les chalenge qui allait
avec
je suis un membre d'une société en
perpétuelle évolution je suis d'une
génération composite fait des baby
boomers qui nous ont appris le travail
des grecs dx qui nous ont appris la
persévérance des y qui nous ont appris à
merde en exergue l'individu et non le
salarié je suis d'une génération de
plein de générations je suis vous alors
finalement pour vous non travailler
ensemble et sommes nous notre diplôme
suis-je mon diplôme
suis-je financière non je ne crois pas
je pense qu'on est bien plus que ça
aujourd'hui et qu'on peut transmettre
encore davantage aujourd'hui peut-être
que quand vous croiserez un jeune
scotché à son téléphone vous dire et
j'ai été pareil mais différemment
quant à moi je vais continue à
m'intéresser à la politique à l'économie
à la cuisine à l'astrologie aux sciences
à tout ce que j'ai envié en fait parce
que j'aurais pas à choisir mon diplôme
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]